und tag liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz herzlich
willkommen unseren ersten
bundesgesundheitsminister professor
doktor karl lauterbach dem präsident des
robert koch instituts professor dr
lothar wieler und dem
vorstandsvorsitzenden der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
dr andreas gassen zu meiner linken es
geht um die krone lage sie alle die das
diese pressekonferenz an den bildschirm
verfolgen dies ist eine
bundespressekonferenz die
bundespressekonferenz ist ein verein
regierungsunabhängiger verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die
gäste zu ihren pressekonferenzen
einladen und wir freuen uns dass sie
heute hier bei uns sind die
das an den bildschirmen verfolgen es
können die gebärdendolmetscherin bei
phoenix verfolgen dafür danke ich
herzlich bei phoenix aber daneben auch
nur bei phoenix herr minister sie haben
das wort ja vielen lieben dank vbv sich
da auch nicht für die einladung in die
bundespressekonferenz ganz herzlich
bedanken
dass wir diese gelegenheit haben wir
kurz auf die
auslage bei fannie mae entwicklung zu
sprechen kommen aus der perspektive der
bundesregierung wir sind in einer
situation wo es uns gelingt die welle
mit der delta variante
langsam aber sicher gut in den griff zu
bekommen wir haben sinkende fallzahlen
die maßnahmen die ergriffen worden sind
wirken sie wirken auch nachhaltig und
das hat auch gott sei dank eine
entlastende wirkung auf die belastung
der krankenhäuser aber auf die
intensivstation
nichtsdestotrotz also müssen wir mit
einer fünften welle jetzt sicher rechnen
in deutschland mittlerweile so viele
unfälle auf der grundlage von
sogenannten waren varianten pc aus die
wir durchführen aber auch so wählens
also pcs dass wir davon ausgehen müssen
dass sich die omikron welle in
deutschland nicht mehr verhindern lässt
und dass hier in deutschland ankommen
gehört darauf bereiten wir uns derzeit
intensiv vor gestern hat die
bundesregierung zusammen mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder
entsprechende beschlüsse gefasst die
wesentlich auch also auf vorarbeiten aus
meinem haus und vorarbeiten des
expertenrates zurückgegangen sind hier
ist von großer bedeutung dass wir
gesehen haben dass die also varianz der
also im fall zahlen der infektionen in
deutschland also sehr breit ist das haus
in der woche infizieren sich dort nicht
weniger als am wochenende
das hat dazu geführt dass wir clubs und
diskotheken ab jetzt schließen werden
wir haben darüber hinaus also maßnahmen
ergriffen die die kontakte reduzieren da
insbesondere eben also die zahl
derjenigen die sich treffen können auch
geimpfte und genesene reduziert auf 10
im innenraum wie draußen wir rechnen
damit dass das also die zahl der
neuinfektionen senken wird aber
wichtiger noch also unser wichtigster
baustein unserer wichtigster bestandteil
der bekämpfung der vor uns liegenden
omikron welle liegt darin dass wir eine
besonders offensive booster kampagne
fahren wie sich erinnern habe ich das
schon vorgetragen in meiner ersten
bundestagsrede zum thema und das ist die
strategie unseres hauses ist es ganz
klar dass an der booster strategie die
mikrowelle nicht ganz verhindern kann
aber sie ist das wichtigste was man tun
kann um zu verhindern dass sehr viele
menschen schwer erkranken wir wissen
mittlerweile aus dem studien und dass
die booster impfungen gut wirken zur
vermeidung von ansteckungen aber auch
von schweren verläufen bei der omicron
variante wir gehen davon aus dass die
wirksamkeit schon eine woche nach der
booster impfung einsetzt also nicht wie
bei der zweite impfung wird
üblicherweise zwei wochen nach der
impfung die wirkung haben wenn wir hier
schon eine woche nach der booster
impfung an der deutliche wirkung das ist
sehr bedeutsam und wir sehen auch in den
studien die
vorliegen das die wirksamkeit der
booster impfung irgendwo zwischen 70 und
80 prozent liegt was die symptomatische
infektion angeht wahrscheinlich ist der
schutz vor schwere erkrankung sehr hoch
hier wurde ich von einem schutz ausgehen
der deutlich über 90 prozent liegt es
könnte sein dass also nach der booster
impfung schwere fälle durch die omikron
variante einer also seltenheit sind das
ist zumindest die arbeitshypothese mit
der wir arbeiten auf jeden fall gehen
wir mit einem schutzfaktor aus der über
90 prozent liegt die booster also
impfung werden wir durchführen im
wesentlichen mit dem impfstoff moderner
zum baden ist dass der impfstoff denen
wir derzeit verfügbar haben wir haben
für die jetzt zweite welle der booster
in punkt haben wir 30 millionen dosen
von moderner zur verfügung wir haben
bisher 27 millionen
menschen mit einer booster impfung schon
versehen aus wir haben eine gute booster
impfung kampagne bisher gefahren hin
wahrscheinlich bis weihnachten die 30
millionen schaffen geworden aber dann
noch einmal 30 millionen menschen mit
einer booster impfung versehen sodass
wir optimalerweise sechzig millionen
oder bis zu 60 millionen
booster geimpfte zum schluss hätten und
dafür haben wir noch 30 millionen
modernen stoff zur verfügung und noch
ungefähr drei millionen dosen bei und
dämmstoff dabei entdeckten stoff ist
etwas knapper wie sich bei der inventur
gezeigt hat die wir zu diesem thema
durchgeführt haben trotzdem ist der
moderne im strand besonders guter
impfstoffen ich möchte diese gelegenheit
nochmal nutzen um auch an die
niederlassen gelassenen kolleginnen und
kollegen aber auch die impfärzte zu
appellieren diesen impfstoff einzusetzen
neuere daten zeigen dass die
autoantikörper konzentration nach der
booster dosis die wir einsetzen die 50er
dosis um den faktor
37 ansteigt das ist ein massiver anstieg
den aus moderner hier auf was somit ein
besonders gut geeigneter booster im
stoff den ich hier so ausdrücklich
empfehlen für diese
für die unter 30 jährigen hat die stiko
empfohlen den bei unter dem stoff
anzusetzen diese empfehlung wird derzeit
von der stiko noch einmal geprüft auch
auf meinem münchen was da also
herauskommt war sich nicht denn die
stiko ist ein unabhängiges gremium
darauf nehmen wir keinen einfluss aber
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt bitte ich die
niedergelassenen kolleginnen und
kollegen den bayern tag im stoff daher
bei den unter 30-jährigen einzusetzen so
dass wir dort auch die booster impfung
mit vollem tempo machen können und den
moderner impfstoff bei den über
30-jährigen die wirksamkeit des moderner
impfstoffes ist mindestens so gut wie
dieses bei und dämmstoffe so dass wir
dann also ohne einschränkung mustern
kann ich freue mich bei dieser
gelegenheit auch also
gassen leute begrüßen zu können der
diese initiativen unterstützt aber dass
gleich etwas dazu sagen und wir werden
auch in den zeiten vom 24 bis zum
neunten erster um eben auch das
engagement der erste schafft zu würdigen
und noch einmal das so aufzurufen das so
viel gebucht hat wird wie irgend möglich
werden wir in der gesamten zeit also vom
24 10 12 bis zum neunten erster werden
wir das sonn und feiertags budget fahren
das heißt es gibt pro impfung dann 36
euro und nicht die 28 euro weil ich weiß
es zu schätzen dass hier erst und ärzte
und auch die daran hängenden teams
bereit sind in den feiertag und zu
impfen ich bitte darum die impfzentren
offen zu halten ich bitte darum die
praxis also alles im zentrum zu nutzen
wir also haben hier aus meiner sicht
eine einmalige chance wenn es uns
gelingen würde 50 bis 60 millionen
menschen in deutschland mit einer
booster impfung zu also versehen dann
schützt das diese menschen von schwerer
krankheit es entschleunigt aber auch
dramatisch die das fortschreiten der
pandemie der also omikron pandemie und
schützt somit zum schluss auch die
ungeimpften
natürlich also machen wir alles was wir
können um die ungeimpften zu erreichen
und wir werden für die umgebenden die
umgehenden warten ja zum teil auch aus
dem stoffe werden wir ein kurzes nowaks
im stoff anbieten dafür haben wir vier
millionen dosen gekauft ich stelle mir
bar zur verfügung so war das werk
liefern kann aber ich will noch mal
darauf hinweisen wollen wir die
ungeimpften mit schützen und viele
ungeimpfte sind keine querdenker das
sind keine menschen dem staat gegenüber
kritisch stehen sonst sind menschen die
zum teil die impfung aufgeschoben haben
die fragen haben aber wollen wir die
umgehenden schützen dann müssen wir
tatsächlich die panne entschleunigen und
diese entschleunigung ist nur möglich
durch eine möglichst schnelle poster
kampagne werden wir die 30 millionen
lebensstoff verbraucht haben die wir
jetzt nutzen kommt mehr impfstoff ich
habe noch einmal 25 millionen
gesamt dosen besorgt von moderner das
sind insgesamt 50 millionen booster
impfung das heißt wir können wirklich
schnell und zu viel boostern wie wir
wollen es kommt nur darauf an wie gut
wird das organisiert haben so viel von
meiner seite gebe zugang vor wewers
vielen dank herr minister herr professor
villa das war ja meine damen und herren
während der feiertage und zum
jahreswechsel wird die epidemiologische
lage nur unvollständig abgebildet sein
warum ist das so das liegt daran dass
viele menschen im urlaub sind und in
folge dessen sind zum beispiel auch
viele arztpraxen geschäfte oder auch
andere institutionen geschlossen wir
wissen dass in dieser zeit meist weniger
personen einen arzt aufsuchen es gibt
weniger testungen am arbeitsplatz und
natürlich auch in den kitas und schulen
denn diese sind ja geschlossen dadurch
werden weniger proben genommen und
dadurch werden auch weniger labor
untersuchungen durchgeführt und das
führt dazu dass natürlich letztlich auch
weniger erreger nachweise an die
gesundheitsämter gemeldet werden aber
wir wissen natürlich trotzdem ganz genau
was zu tun ist welche maßnahmen
umzusetzen sind am wichtigsten ist neben
dem impfen je weniger menschen
zusammenkommen je kleiner das
kontaktnetzwerk ist desto weniger
verbreitet sich das virus
unser aller verhalten ist hier wirklich
entscheidend in den vergangenen wochen
waren die fallzahlen rückläufig aber
leider ist das noch kein zeichen für
eine entspannung
kein incident von fast 300 ist immer
noch zu hoch und über 50 kreise haben
heute noch immer in tänzen über 500
kliniken intensivstation sind weiterhin
am limit viele operationen werden nach
wie vor abgesagt es liegen immer noch
etwa viereinhalb tausend cupid patienten
auf intensivstationen
auch das ist immer noch ein hohes niveau
und es werden weiterhin woche für woche
etwa 2000 todesfälle in verbindung mit
kurven 19 registriert auch lancôme witt
beeinträchtigt natürlich weiterhin sehr
sehr viele betroffene und deswegen
müssen wir die immer noch sehr hohen
fallzahlen weiter runter bekommen
auch weil wir damit rechnen müssen dass
die fallzahlen in absehbarer zeit wieder
steigen und vor allem durch micon muss
mit einer infektionswelle gerechnet
werden von einer bislang noch nicht
gesehenen dynamik in immer mehr ländern
verbreitet sich omikron sehr schnell
extrem schnell zb in großbritannien oder
unseren nachbarländern dänemark und
frankreich
in deutschland sind nach den neuesten
daten bislang rund 540 fälle und
verdachtsfälle als robert koch institut
übermittelt worden dass der heutige
stand die daten sind überwiegend ein bis
zwei wochen altes wissen sie wir schauen
in den meldedaten ja immer zurück wegen
des melde verzugs und insbesondere auch
wegen des zeitbedarf für eine sequenz
analyse und über die feiertage ist wie
gesagt zu erwarten dass weniger proben
genommen und damit auch analysiert
werden können aber der trend ist
glasklar bei einer verdopplung zeit von
etwa drei tagen
könnte die neue variante in den nächsten
ein zwei spätestens drei wochen bereits
die mehrzahl aller infektionsfälle in
unserem land ausmachen wir können nach
wie vor nicht sicher einschätzen ob
oregon weniger kann gemacht aber selbst
wenn dies so wäre und mir kann es extrem
ansteckend und kann dem immunsystem
leichter entkommen das führt auch bei
genesenen und zweimal geimpften häufiger
zu infektionen und diese können eben
auch weitergegeben werden die nicht oder
nicht vollständig geimpften sind
weiterhin stark gefährdet daher ist zu
erwarten dass sich die situation in
kürze wieder verschärfen wird wenn es
nicht gelingt die dynamik der mikrowelle
mit strikten maßnahmen zu bremsen muss
aufgrund der in kurzer zeit zu
erwartenden hohen erkrankungszahlen mit
einer überlastung des gesundheitssystems
gerechnet werden und nicht nur das es
muss auch mit einer beeinträchtigung
kritischer versorgungsstrukturen
gerechnet werden denn wenn viele
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen zur
gleichen zeit erkranken oder als enge
kontaktpersonen in quarantäne müssen
dann fehlen sie natürlich bei der arbeit
die gute nachricht mit einer dritten
impfung verbessert sich der schutz vor
einer symptomatischen inflation auf etwa
70 bis 80 prozent und das ist wirklich
viel deswegen ist die
auffrischungsimpfung so wichtig aber
natürlich auch die noch fehlen erst und
zweitens weil nikon eine so hohe dynamik
bringt hat das lka am montag seine
risikobewertung zur vip 19 geändert für
die gruppe der ungeimpften wird die
infektions gefährdung als sehr hoch
eingeschätzt es gibt in deutschland auch
etwa elf millionen erwachsene die
umkämpft sind obwohl es ausreichend
fundierte daten zur wirksamkeit und zur
sicherheit der impfstoffe gibt für die
chinesen und geimpften mit zweimaliger
impfung schätzen wir die infektions
gefährdung als hoch ein und für die drei
mal geimpft als moderat auch die
ständige impfkommission hat rasch auf
die zunehmende verbreitung von omikron
reagiert und gestern ihre empfehlungen
zur auffrischungsimpfung angepasst die
stiko empfiehlt die auffrischung mit nun
mit einem verkürzten abstand von
mindestens drei monaten zur
grundimmunisierung dazu zufügen bei der
auf frische impfung sollte man nicht auf
einen wunsch im stoff warten sondern das
nehmen was vorhanden ist beide
impfstoffe von biotech und moderner
führen mit der auffrischung zu einem
guten schutz vor der omicron variant
ja wir alle möchten die feiertage und
mit der familie und mit freunden und
verwandten verbringen das weihnachtsfest
soll aber nicht der funke sein der das
omikron feuer entfacht im gegenteil wir
alle müssen dafür sorgen diese zeit
zwischen jahr zu nutzen um die dynamik
aus dem infektionsgeschehen
herauszunehmen ich bitte sie deshalb
eindringlich verbringen sie diese zeit
wirklich nur im kleineren kreis von
freunden verwandten und familie bitte
schränken sie ihre kontakte auf das
nötigste 1 craft sie möglichst wenige
und wenn dann immer dieselben menschen
in einem festen sozialen kreis
am sichersten ist es natürlich wenn alle
vollständig zweimal geimpft sind und
eine auffrischungsimpfung hatten wenn
sie sich mit menschen aus risikogruppen
treffen zum beispiel alten hoch alten
chronisch kranken dann sollten sie sich
vorher bitte immer unbedingt testen auch
wenn sie vollständig geimpft sind und
verzichten sie auf reisen die nicht
unbedingt notwendig sind lassen sie uns
gemeinsam dafür sorge tragen dass die
bevorstehende mikrowelle möglichst flach
verläuft
in der professor der gast hat das wort
vielen dank ja sehr damen und herren sie
haben es gilt minister laut aber hat
skizziert wie wir trotz der anstehenden
und zu befürchtenden omi von welle von
der wir alle noch nicht wissen was sie
für uns wirklich in der realität dann
bedeuten wird wie wir trotzdem
da das ganze mit mit impfung in den
griff bekommen und jetzt stellt sich
natürlich für viele von ihnen die frage
ist das realistisch dieses ich ziehe und
dann kann ich sie an der stelle
beruhigen das ist realistisch und wir
haben tatsächlich auch in der
vergangenheit in einem selbst für mich
fast überraschenden tempo diese booster
impfungen hinbekommen es war sie haben
das gehört immer die zahl 30 millionen
auffrischimpfung bis ende des jahres
ausgerufen worden und da haben wir schon
alle geraten wenn wir das schaffen wäre
ich kann ihnen sagen stand gestern sind
wir bei knapp 28 millionen 100000 also
sogar noch etwas höher als die zahl der
minister gerade von kommunizierte habe
ich vor 10 minuten bekommen die
niedergelassenen ärzte und ärzte mit den
teams haben wirklich hier
großes geleistet das muss man so sagen
wir haben so viele impfungen pro woche
wie noch nie zuvor in deutschland impfen
über sechs millionen menschen jede woche
und sie können vielleicht aus weil ich
dann auch die 30 millionen die dann noch
anstehen für die verbleibende
bevölkerung ist letztlich in einem guten
monat bis ende januar zu schaffen damit
ist deutschland weit über dem eu schnitt
auch das muss glaube ich mal deutlich
gemacht werden wir holen das vereinigte
königreich ein das deutlich früher
angefangen hat zwei dieser drei
impfungen werden den praxen gemacht in
der letzten woche waren fünf millionen
impfungen praxen davon 4,2 millionen
booster impfung was zeigt auch die
ersten zwei teamkollegen gott sei dank
wieder zu insgesamt beteiligen sich
aktuell knapp 84.000 kolleginnen und
kollegen an den impfungen ziemlich genau
hälfte haus erste hälfte fachärzte und
die entstehen natürlich diese hohen
impfzahlen nicht nur durch den
zunehmenden zahl von kolleginnen und
kollegen sondern auch durch mehr info
impfstelle das ist gut im leben tages
schnitt sind das 27.000 tägliche
impfungen ich möchte an der stelle noch
mal ganz herzlich bei den kollegen und
kollegen in den praxen bedanken das ist
eine enorme zusatzbelastung auch für die
teams und das ist nicht
selbstverständlich findet trotzdem
mal eine erwähnung wert dass das hier
neben der normalen versorgung geleistet
wird also das ziel 30 millionen bis
jahresende ist erreichbar da glaube ich
brauche mal keine zweifel mehr daran
heben und ich glaube auch dass wir den
rest der zur oster bevölkerung bei
ausreichend impfstoff kapazitäten das
scheint der fall zu sein dann auch im
januar
entsprechend boostern können der
minister hat schon die größenordnung
genannt die zur verfügung stehen auch
mal auf die wertigkeit auch gerade der
brüstung durch moderne hingewiesen die
aktuellen zahlen sind sehr ermutigend
damit hat man tatsächlich wieder einen
sehr wirkungsvollen schutz erstimpfung
auch da gibt es positives zu berichten
nicht in dem umfang geben uns wünschen
würden aber immerhin werden jede woche
jetzt eine eine halbe million
erstimpfung erreicht auch das ist ein
positives signal da sind 20 kinder
impfung aber nichtsdestotrotz scheint es
auch zunehmend doch erwachsen zu geben
die den wert der impfung für sich
anerkennen und wir können an der stelle
nur noch mal dazu aufrufen das ist das
schärfste schwert im kampf gegen korona
ist die impfung vollständig geimpft und
nach einer gewissen zeit die booster
rung nowaks wurde schon erwähnt steht an
wann genau und welcher menge nowaks zur
verfügung steht wissen wir noch nicht
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wir hier
den ein oder anderen noch erreichen der
bisher mit den mma impfstoffen haderte
die botschaft ist also aus meiner sicht
wir haben eine eine gute chance mit der
booster kampagne in dem hohen tempo und
ich sag mal mit der vernunft der
menschen die sich völlig unfähig das
haben wir die letzten wochen gezeigt die
zahlen sinken die menschen passen mit
mehr auf sich und andere auf glaube ich
kriegen wir das hin haben wir eine gute
chance hier nicht vor eine
unüberbrückbare
infektions und krankenstands wann zu
laufen und ich glaube das ist
zunächst mal eine gute botschaft es
kamen auch die gewässer wieder als
angesprochen kritische infrastruktur wie
gefährlich ist es wenn uns plötzlich in
großer zahl natürlich auch
kollegin kollegen und mitarbeitern in
praxen oder kliniken wegbrechen da wir
rund 100.000 praxen haben sind die
natürlich nicht für infektionen gefeiert
aber sie dieses system an sich ist etwas
residente weil wir dann einzelne kleine
einheiten haben die mal ausfahren können
dass die in der gesamtheit
flächendeckend ausfallen ist
unwahrscheinlich insofern sind wir auch
hier hoffnungsfroh dass wir die
impfkampagne ohne wesentliche tipps auch
über die weihnachtstage fortführen
können ich finde es ein sehr gutes
signal den kollegen hier auch eine
entsprechende wirtschaftliche
anerkennung zukommen zu lassen weil das
natürlich auch zwischen den tagen eine
zusätze herausfahren ist auch mit
personal war ja viele medizinische
fachangestellte auch kinder haben das zu
die müssen die auffassung trotzdem
glaube ich wir kriegen das gemeinsam gut
hin die resonanz aus den kollegen ist
sehr wohl ich habe heute morgen noch mit
den kv chefs der länder gesprochen und
auch hier gibt es eine breite zustimmung
zur impfung booster kampagne man wünscht
natürlich noch ein bisschen abbau der
bürokratie da können wir sicherlich bei
den gelegenheiten auch darüber sprechen
aber insgesamt glaube ich sind wir gut
aufgestellt und können durchaus mit
einer gewissen selbstbewusstsein und
hoffnung in die zukunft schauen dank
adapter gassen der hand jetzt zeit für
fragen bis halb zwei dann müssen wir
listen für die nächste große konferenz
damit dass hier auch alles ordnungsgemäß
abläuft ich habe bereits jetzt ungefähr
20 fragen vorliegen von kolleginnen und
kollegen die sich gemeldet haben ich
versuche hier einen einigermaßen guten
ausgleich zu schaffen zwischen innen und
online zugespielten fragen die erste
hatte christian sei
im grunde sind es 33 kurze an jeden
einzelnen herr gassen ist moderner
genauso einfach zu vermitteln in den
praxen biontech im umgang damit herr
lauterbach boostern wichtig war sprachen
sie oder was sagen sie zu den kindern
die sich jetzt zweimal geimpft haben
müssen die auch gepustet werden vor
allen dingen auch die die im schon im
juni oder im juli oft empfohlen sind die
müssten könnten jetzt auch weil sie
sagen drei monate und das problem ist
moderner ist glaube ich für gut 30 regel
nicht die richtige aber das können sie
sicherlich besser beantworten und herr
bielern muss eigentlich es früher seien
mit den kontakt beschränkungen das was
wir gesagt haben als der 28 dezember um
die mikrowelle zu brechen und auch weil
ja nicht getestet wird zum teil und die
praxen zu sind vielen dank ich hätte
noch vergessen zu sagen dass wir immer
so wie sonst auch immer eine frage eine
nachfrage stellen das wäre so nett vom
zeitbudget was wir an die anderen
kollegen schuldig ist
trotzdem ist
also ganz kurz zur anwendung der
grundsätzliches moderne natürlich in der
praxis genauso als wenn das problem das
haben sie damit impliziert gefragt ist
dadurch dass die weit größer sind und
wir bei den boston bruins als 20 dosen
aus einem weil bekommen was an sich gut
ist ist es organisatorisch etwas
aufwendig und deshalb vielleicht an der
stelle der appell die menschen sollten
wirklich versuchen sie in den praxen
termine geben zuerst hatte die
organisation erheblich es ist dann
relativ unproblematisch so ist der
wirkstoff hochwirksam keine frage aber
die packungsgröße erfordert eine gewisse
vor laufende planung deshalb bitte nicht
einfach in die praxen kommen sondern
vielleicht kurz vorher
vielen dank die
kinder ist nicht zugelassen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wenn sie aber vorgenommen wird
weil es sich um zugelassene impfstoff
verhandelt übernimmt der bund die
haftung
ja zu den kontakt einschränkungen also
die der gestrige mpk beschluss war er
sehr eindeutig dort steht ja immer dass
spätestens zum 28
diese kontakt mal kontakt einschränkung
maßnahmen vorgenommen werden sollen
insofern ist der zeitraum wann das in
den einzelnen bundesländern wirklich
gemacht wird ja sowieso offen aber ich
denke was sehr wichtig ist und was ja
auch der expertenrat am wochenende klar
gemacht hat und was auch in dem pkw
steht natürlich wird unabhängig davon ja
an jeden einzelnen appelliert dass er
oder sie schon die kontakte so gut wie
möglich einschränkt und das ist das
entscheidende das haben wir glaube ich
in dieser pandemie die ganze zeit immer
gelernt es hängt wahnsinnig davon ab wie
sich die menschen unser land verhalten
in rahmen ihrer möglichkeiten und wir
sehen in den letzten wochen und monaten
dass dort sehr viel verständnis ist und
dass das von der mehrheit der menschen
getragen wird und das ist das warum wir
ja auch zahlen sehen die runtergehen in
den meisten bundesländern insofern ist
er schon adäquat
aber rtl eine frage an den
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hatte
fanden die maske auf lassen wenn sie
fragen das hat sich hier ganz gut
bewährt danke herr lauterbach
wenn es so wichtig ist dass die zweite
booster werde so weiterläuft wie die
erste zu sein werden verspricht wie
steht es denn damit der ausreichende
versorgung mit impfstoff also sie
sprachen über wie sieht es aus mit
bayern-chef weil 30 hat dann doch eben
auf diesen impfstoff angewiesen ist
inwiefern könnte darin mangel eventuell
eben den fortgang dieser welle hängen ja
vielen dank für die falle die also
antwort ist ganz einfach wir haben 30
millionen dosen booster dosen von
moderner jetzt zur verfügung für die
nächsten drei wochen zehn millionen pro
woche und wir haben insgesamt also über
diese zeit drei millionen bei und deckt
zur verfügung wo woche also die erste
woche 1,2 millionen die woche darauf 0,8
die woche darauf 12 mehr ist es nicht
ich hatte schon ein anderer gelegen hat
darauf hingewiesen dass wir im rahmen
einer inventur also festgestellt hatten
dass nicht so viel bei und tag im stoff
also beschafft worden war wir arbeiten
allerdings fieberhaft also jetzt daran
noch weiteren dem stoff zu besorgen
ich kann auf jeden fall ankündigen dass
wir also 25 millionen dosen moderner
impfstoff noch beschaffen konnten im
anschluss an die 30 millionen die wsh
diese 25 millionen sind doppelt rosen
das wäre dann so viel dass man damit 50
millionen usd impfungen machen könnte
und es wird gleichzeitig auch versucht
also bei dem stoff zusätzlichen bei und
dem stoff zu besorgen
da sind wir mit mehreren ländern also
für den direktkauf bilateralen kauf im
gespräch darüber kann ich aber erst
vortragen wenn diese gespräche
erfolgreich sind
ich habe eine frage von anno fricke von
der erste zeitung an sie herr minister
lauterbach da geht es um datenschutz und
statistik wie können die daten der
bereits geimpften unter einhaltung aller
datenschutzbestimmungen bei den
niedergelassenen ärzten und den
impfzentren abgerufen werden daran
arbeiten wir derzeit an es gibt ja zum
beispiel auch die frage für deutschland
ein im register ein ja oder nein das
prüfen wir wir prüfen also wie die daten
derjenigen die bereits geimpft worden
sind also in ein solches register werden
das es je gab
eingepflegt werden könnten das sind
große aufgaben an denen wir derzeit also
arbeiten aber auf der anderen seite ist
so zum jetzigen zeitpunkt muss es
erstmal darum geben gehen mit möglichst
großem tempo
unbürokratisch viel zu ende es geht um
den schutz der bevölkerung das heißt es
ist jetzt im moment nicht
ist nicht die gelegenheit wo ich eine
weitere bürokratische hürde bereit wäre
einzuführen und zur dokumentation
sondern jetzt muss wirklich im
bestehenden rahmen so schnell wie
möglich geimpft werden
sebastian heinrich vom nach watson herr
lauterbach her wieder was gerade viele
junge menschen nicht verstehen warum
dürfen auch nach den jüngsten im pk
beschlüssen cafés und bars weiterhin
geöffnet sein clubs aber nicht also in
beiden arten von lokalen wird alkohol
konsumiert in beiden die menschen
bisweilen eng beieinander
marcus schulz hat von der kosmetischen
unterscheidung da gesprochen die da
getroffen wird kein unterschied macht
können sie das erklären diesen
unterschied
also ich kann das so etwas sagen es
kommt immer darauf an also was jetzt im
vordergrund des betriebs steht auch das
also große tanz gelegenheiten sind dann
zum teil
150 200 menschen zusammengekommen sind
oder in innenräumen und daneben 50 und
das haben wir es halt sehr stark
eingeschränkt die gastronomie
der verzehr im vordergrund steht hat
also von den also
pandemischen
herausforderungen nicht genau diese
bedeutung aber selbstverständlich ist
das was man im blick haben muss wir
werden ja das was wir tun weiter
auswerten das was wir jetzt gemacht
haben geht im wesentlichen auf
empfehlungen und auch gespräche mit dem
expertenrat zurück und darauf an was
bezogen
das ist vielleicht noch
bietet idee von der bild
herr wille hat gestern mit der
veröffentlichung eines extra papiers für
erheblichen wirbel erheblichen wirbel
gesorgt auch in der mpk es gab da
relativ heftige äußerungen von
bundeskanzler und auch von ihnen herr
lauterbach und daher die frage stehen
sie zu herrn wieder fest im sattel und
an herrn wieder die frage warum haben
sie gestern also so kurz nachdem
experten raten sie selber angehören ein
weitergehendes papier veröffentlicht
unterlassen was haben sie gedacht als
sie das gelesen habe ist das glaube ich
endlich angekommen mit der einen frage
ich dann schick ich jetzt mal noch einer
hinterher
und zwar fragte timm cent ivanyi von rnd
sie herr lauterbach wie verärgert sind
sie über lka-präsident wieder wegen der
forderungen nach oben gehen abschreckung
und das thematisch daran hast ja vielen
dank hier kamen wir jetzt mal die frage
ob ich zu einem wlan noch stehe
das lässt sich leicht beantworten sonst
sehr serie nicht und
und die zweite frage also verärgert das
sind interna
es ist so also in meinem haus gibt es
keine zensur was wissenschaftliche
arbeiten das wird es auch nicht geben
von daher bin ich also dankbar wenn also
wenn wissenschaftliche auswertungen mich
erreichen hier war es so dass sie mich
nicht mehr erreicht hatten vor der
eigentlichen sitzung da wird die
abstimmung optimiert werden aber ich
will ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen ich
hab mir mal gesagt also dass also einen
kern baustein meiner arbeit darin liegen
wird dass ich mich sehr stark auch am
jeweiligen wissenschaftlichen
sachverstand orientiere und da ist auch
das robert koch institut eine ganz
zentrale quelle
ich habe dem nichts hinzuzufügen
sie müssen schon ins mikrofon sprechen
das hätte vorteile der versicherer
wieder nicht wissen auch bei lauterbach
und auch noch zu ihnen steht sondern
warum dieses geld getan haben und dann
sollte ich doch ganz klare antwort ja
das robert koch institut gibt ja
kontinuierlich empfehlung heraus das ist
ja unsere aufgabe das hat sich natürlich
in den letzten zwei jahren auch nichts
geändert
ich habe eine frage von der kollegin
lisa braun von der presseagentur
gesundheit die fragt auch nach den
jungen bund länder beschlossen
stichwort wissenschaftliche evidenz
corinna kennt keine ländergrenzen und
kein weihnacht welche politische rolle
hat das weihnachtsfest bei den jüngsten
und länder beschlossen gespielt vielen
dank für diese wichtige frage
wir sind zunächst davon ausgegangen auf
der grundlage von auswertungen und der
vergangen waren das tage dass also die
weihnachtstage keine besondere also
epidemisch herausforderung darstellen
die fans in den letzten jahren nicht
wesentlich gestiegen trotzdem ist das
für mich noch mal eine gelegenheit
anzuknüpfen dann das was herr gassen
auch schon dankenswerterweise gesagt
hatte wir müssen hier in den
weihnachtstagen besonders aufeinander
achtgeben und ich rate daher allen die
ihre verwandten besuchen die gemeinsam
also nach hause kommen ich rate allen
sich vorher zu testen also nicht nur
denjenigen die ältere besuchen die als
ungeimpfte besuchen sondern die testung
vor der abreise
bevorzugt mehrere tests hintereinander
also ein zweites hintereinander das gibt
die mit großem abstand größte sicherheit
weil man sich dann auch nicht auf der
fahrt zur zu den verwandten infiziert
und kleine gruppen sind besser als große
gruppen gerade bei älteren menschen ist
großer wert darauf zu legen dass man
fragt sind die älteren menschen schon
gebucht hat jahr sondern waren war die
booster impfung
daher also
mit kleinen gruppen sich treffen und
wenn immer möglich das wäre der zentrale
baustein antigen testen an mehreren
tagen hintereinander
fabian busch von web.de und gmx.de
lauter noch im koalitionsvertrag steht
dass das lka künftig wissenschaftlich
weisungsgebunden arbeiten soll bleibt
das weiterhin das ziel denn wenn das
papier gestern vom rk ii so viele
aufruhr erregt hat dann zeigt das wir
dass die politik da vielleicht gar nicht
bereit ist
ich glaube ich habe die frage schon
beantwortet
wissenschaftlicher sachverstand vom
expertenrat vom rk ii auch von
unabhängigen experten mit denen ich in
regelmäßigen austausch bin übrigens auch
in england selbst ich werde heute
nachmittag mit dem englischen
gesundheitsminister und auch mit
englischen wissenschaftlern mich noch
einmal über die omikron lage ebendort
auseinandersetzen das ist also etwas was
meine arbeit prägen wird und dass da ist
auch das lka ein ganz zentraler baustein
herrn buchsteiner rufe ich von hier aus
zu dass mir ihre fragen beantwortet
scheint bitte melden sie sich noch mal
falls sie das anders sehen die nächste
frage von bernhard junginger von der
augsburger allgemeinen zeitung und geht
es um thema kritische infrastruktur zu
welchem zeitpunkt ist nach den
erkenntnissen des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums eine
gefahr für die kritische infrastruktur
durch omikron infektionen beim personal
zu befürchten
ja das können wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch nicht sagen wir modellieren also
die entwicklung und sind auf jeden fall
in intensiver vorberatung also was alle
bereiche der kritischen infrastruktur
angeht das sind also nicht nur die
medizinischen bereiche sondern das geht
über polizei feuerwehr strom wasser so
auch lebensmittelversorgung alles wird
derzeit im prinzip monitor irrt und
vorbereitet aber ob und wann uns an der
welle so hart treffen würde dass diese
notfall pläne umgesetzt werden müssen
das wissen wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht wir hoffen dass noch abwenden zu
können im wesentlichen auch durch die
also jetzt an gepflegten
kontakt beschränkungen und die poster
kampagne
dann geht's mit den gästen weiterhin sei
ein freier journalist
herr villa der die bundesländer runde
gestern hat sich ihrer beschlussfassung
explizit an dem beschluss des
expertenrates dem sie angehören
orientiert was hat sie veranlasst und
die frage ist noch nicht beantwortet
was hat sie veranlasst wissen worauf die
bund länder nicht geeinigt haben dann
doch zeitnah eine davon abweichende
schärfere positionen zu formulieren
also ob wie gesagt dazu hatte ich mich
auch schon geäußert der expertenrat wenn
sie das papier wirklich gründlich lesen
dann stellen sie fest dass dort keine
konkreten empfehlungen gemacht werden
sondern dort steht ja eine analyse der
lage und die aufforderung dass etwas
getan werden muss und das wird ja auch
getan und das ist eben eine institution
die das in konkrete empfehlungen dann
ummünzt das ist ja in dem expertenbeirat
nicht getan worden insofern ist es ja
keinerlei widerspruch es ist eigentlich
aber auch keine antwort denn
die bund länder runde hat sich gestern
sozusagen eine interpretation der
empfehlung zu eigen gemacht beschlüsse
oder seid ihr mit daraus abgeleitet das
wussten sie sie haben eine empfehlung
mit anderen schärferen daten
veröffentlicht noch mal die frage was
hat sie zu der
schärferen variante für anders man
steckt auch die kritik dass das was bund
länder beschließen oder vorschlagen
nicht ausreichend ist
also ich hab das so in erinnerung dass
unsere empfehlung vor dem beschluss der
mpk auf der website
wir wussten aber doch mit verlaub was
die ministerpräsidenten und der kanzler
sagen würden das ist ja innerhalb von
zwei tagen wie die runde selbst gesagt
hat zusammengestellt worden sie wussten
dass und in kenntnis dieses
vorher gemacht so was war jetzt die
frage die frage in frage war
warum kommen sie tschuldigung mit einem
formalen argument wenn sie sagen wir
haben es da bei
straßenlicht sie wussten wie die bund
länder runde sich positionieren wollen
er noch haben sie eine scharfe
empfehlung ausgesprochen warum ich kann
nicht in die zukunft schauen ich weiß
nicht was
beschlossen wird in der zukunft
können wir sagen vielen dank also es
wurde ja schon also darauf hingewiesen
wir müssen nach vorne blicken
wir müssen nach vorne blicken wie
schaffen wir das jetzt und wir haben
hier klare beschlüsse gestern gefasst
das sind beschlüsse die werden den
abfall der fälle weiter beschleunigen
wir werden dann einen weiteren rückgang
der fälle sehen und dann werden in
dieser zeit die poster kampagne fahren
somit also versuchen wir eine besonders
schwere mikrowelle noch abzuwenden man
muss nach vorne blicken und ich
persönlich finde die diskussion also war
das jetzt also ungünstig so platziert
oder nicht also das finde ich nicht so
also besonders interessant sondern ist
noch gemeinsam jetzt schauen wie kriegen
wir das bewältigt und ich da bin ich
zuversichtlich
das ziel ist der identischen dass man
auch mal sagen also alle die
entscheidenden unserem land kann mir
dasselbe ziel nämlich wir wollen die
fälle senken und das gelingt ja auch
seit einigen wochen
ich habe jetzt frage fragen zur test
kapazitäten da würde ich gerne zwei
zusammenfassen die in dieselbe richtung
gehen jungen klecken klöckner vom
handelsblatt fragt sie herr lauterbach
und herrn wieder welche erkenntnisse
haben sie über die test kapazitäten
unternehmen befürchten oder vermelden
bereits engpässe und dazu hatte ich noch
eine weitere frage gesehen von sebastian
huld von n tv
bezogen auf ihre empfehlung dass die
bürger sich testen sollen der
einzelhandel bietet aber kaum selbst
tests an schreibt der kollege holt wird
der bund sich dieser versorgung dieses
versorgungs man jetzt annehmen
in der tat wir haben den einzelnen
regionen jetzt so die belastungsgrenze
bei der pcr testung erreicht das ist so
aber
es ist keine überforderung das heißt zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt gibt es keine region
wo die pcr testung wenn ich mir
durchgeführt werden kann sonst kann
allenfalls zu einer leichten verzögerung
der mitteilung der ergebnisse kommen was
die anti gen tests angeht sind wir also
nicht ins system der zentralen
beschaffung sondern das regelt der markt
selbst mit dem unternehmen in kontakt
und uns wird mitgeteilt dass der bedarf
gedeckt werden könne
ich gehe hier nur zur information der
kolleginnen und kollegen die es sehr
eilig haben der reihenfolge nach vorbei
wir uns hier in teufels küche ich
hinweise 35 ried ist ja nix
also pardon ich hatte
minister und mehr wieder ich hätte eine
frage noch mal zu der expertenrat
geschichte sowie das vorgestern und
gestern glauben ist entsteht der
eindruck dass im expertenrat zwar ein
einstelliges ergebnis herrscht das dann
aber nur ein kompromiss als eine art
kleinste gemeinsame nenner und einzelne
mitglieder des expertenrats sowie er
wieder oder das rkw als ganzes dann
weitergehende vorschläge haben ist das
eigentlich sinnvoll wenn der expertenrat
sich nicht mit 19 stimmen von 19 auf das
bestmögliche einigen sondern nur auf das
was man sich halt als kompromiss
reinigen kann
ja vielen dank das ist schlicht nicht so
also ich mich auch mit den mitgliedern
des expertenrats im austausch und wohne
den also sitzungen typischerweise auch
bei und das abzuqualifizieren als den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner ist nicht
richtig der expertenrat war sehr klar
darin wie also gravierend die welle sein
wird die wir hier erwarten müssen ist
auch sehr klar darüber gewesen wie
gefährlich omikron ist ist auch sehr
klage darüber gewesen dass wir hier
sogar ein schutz der kritischen
infrastruktur also vornehmen müssen ist
doch sehr klar darüber gewesen dass wir
jetzt nicht ausschließen können dass die
omikron variante ähnlich schwer verläuft
also wie die data variante das sind
alles sehr klare aussagen und auch keine
aussagen die also grund zur freude oder
zur entwarnung machen und daher ist
meine einschätzung die dass sie hier
einen graben auf touren der möglichkeit
nicht besteht und die ergebnisse im
expertenrat sind also alarmierend
gewesen und das haben wir auch umgesetzt
und berücksichtigt ich würde das gerne
noch mal gern zumindest einfach wirklich
ganz sachlich und nüchtern darzustellen
mir liegt dieses papier des
expertenrates vor da steht in das ist
der letzte absatz das ist eine
schlussfolgerung zeitnah notwendige
maßnahmen aus dem geschilderten szenario
ergibt sich handlungsbedarf bereits für
die kommenden tage wirksame bundesweit
abgestimmte gegenmaßnahmen zur kontrolle
desinfektions geschehens sind
vorzubereiten insbesondere gut geplante
und gut kommunizierte kontakt
beschränkungen dann steht da die aktuell
geltenden maßnahmen müssen darüber
hinaus noch stringenter fortgeführt
werden ich wüsste nicht wo das
irgendeine interpretationsspielraum
offen lässt aber der expertenrat hat
eben keine konkreten maßnahmen
beschlossen ist kein kompromiss papier
sondern ist eine sehr nüchterne analyse
die fordert dass stringentere maßnahmen
fortgeführt werden müssen
dann gehe ich weiter mit einer frage von
charlotte kurz von der pharmazeutischen
zeitung die nach nowaks fragt sie herr
minister lauterbach wann werden die
ersten nowaks impfstoffe nach
deutschland geliefert und verändert
vielen dank wir haben vier millionen
impfdosen bestellt sind mit dem
unternehmen in kontakt und rechnen mit
einer lieferung im januar
dann gehts hier vorne weiterhin seien
noch mal jörg ratzsch von dpa direkt an
herrn wieder nachfragen gestern abend
die zufrieden oder unzufrieden sind sie
denn mit den ergebnissen der bund länder
warten also ist sind stringentere
maßnahmen sie werden das
infektionsgeschehen deutlich vor langsam
und das ist sehr sehr gut und ansonsten
möchte ich das noch mal wiederholen wir
machen seit jahren empfehlungen immer
wieder empfehlungen und die werden wir
auch weitermachen und die umsetzung
dieser empfehlungen ist aufgabe der
politik ob ich zufrieden oder
unzufrieden ist ist völlig irrelevant
dann hab ich eine frage von patrick
hollstein von apotheke adhoc 17 minister
lauterbach welche pläne und erwartungen
haben sie an praxen und apotheken als
teil der kritischen infrastruktur um im
fall von der rasant steigenden
infektionszahlen die versorgung zu
sichern
ja zunächst hoffen wir natürlich diese
rasant steigende infektionszahlen
abzuwenden aber
selbstverständlich sind praxen und auch
apotheken und auch krankenhäuser
zentraler baustein der kritischen
infrastruktur und wir haben ja hier in
früheren wählen also schon eine gewisse
erfahrung damit glaubt was ist also was
es bedeuten kann ich hoffe dass wir hier
also diesmal
besser gerüstet sind wegen der sehr
hohen impfquote die wir in diesen
bereichen erreicht haben und die booster
impfung gerade in diesen bereichen ist
von größter bedeutung und daher hoffe
ich dass wir hier also die infrastruktur
geschützt haben selbstverständlich
werden pläne gemacht was passiert wenn
zum beispiel bestimmte krankenhäuser
nicht voll betrieben werden können
was machen wir zum beispiel mit reha
kliniken können rehakliniken dann auch
finden also bereich der akutversorgung
herangezogen werden das wird alles
geprüft und vorbereitet aber ich glaube
dass wir jetzt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
darf auch noch hoffen können dass uns
dies spart platz vielleicht vergessen
dazu etwas sagen ja sie haben es im
grundsatz schon richtig gesagt wir haben
hier zum einen das muss man glaube ich
noch mal raus stellen gerade in praxen
und auch in den kliniken sehr hohe
impfen auch booster quoten das ist
eigentlich der wirksamste schutz also
ich gehe aus der eigenen struktur da
sind alle geben schon gewusst hat und
bei den praxen kommt noch dazu dass hier
ähnlich wie die apotheke natürlich
dezentral sind also wenn dann einer
ausfällt heißt das ja nicht dass die
ganze struktur gefährdet ist und
ansonsten müssen wir da
ergäben werde ich die situation dass wir
die arena unterschiedlich sein da
braucht man nicht viel phantasie zu dass
das möglicherweise in sachsen thüringen
er auftreten kann also in schleswig
holstein da muss man sich da dinge zu
überlegen eine möglichkeit sind
vernetzung das geschieht bei den praxen
häufig informell schon also ich bin
relativ zuversichtlich dass wir nicht
erleben werden dass die menschen nicht
mehr versorgte können trotzdem müssen
wir achtsamer sein und uns auch mit
solchen eventualitäten befassen aber
grundsätzlich halte ich die struktur der
niedergelassenen praxen und in der folge
dann auch die der apotheke für recht
resilient
jetzt wenn ich noch mal eine nachricht
an bernhard walter von der badischen
zeitung die frage scheint mir auch
beantwortet zu sein die er mir hier
eingespielt hat sonst bitte nochmal
melden und herr hoffmann hat das wort
vom strahlen eine frage zum thema nowak
wir haben gesagt im januar werden die
für die millionen dosen geliefert haben
sie sich eigentlich eine spezielle
verteilung überlegte nowaks gilt ja
gerade bei ihm skeptikern er als
mögliche lösung das heißt wird er im
osten geliefert oder wie sieht das aus
der verteilung von oberrang
ja vielen dank eine spezielle verteilung
haben das nicht überlegt sondern
normalerweise ist das ja ein system von
angebot und nachfrage wenn wir den
impfstoff im
januar bekommen dann glaube ich wird er
von dort
angefragt sein wo diejenigen die diesen
impfstoff zu bevorzugen
nachfragen das heißt ich rechne dann
tatsächlich mit also eine größere
nachfrage
in einigen bundesländern beispielsweise
sachsen sachsen anhalt
möglicherweise auch in teilen von bayern
das würde mich nicht überraschen was wir
nicht machen werden wir also
kontingentieren den impfstoff nicht und
wir werden auch mehr von dem impfstoff
also beschaffen wollen und wir haben
auch von dem echten tod impfstoff
wallnöfer elf millionen dosen bestellt
wer noch nicht so gelassen ist
dann habe ich eine frage von markus
wacket von reuters an sie herr
lauterbach wie deutschland das pfizer
medikament
axel vieth und das merkt präparat
cera wir sie sehen ich bin damit nicht
so vertraut kaufen um sich
beziehungsweise bei der eu dafür
einsetzen ja vielen dank motto vera wir
haben wir gekauft das hier haben wir
eine bestellung verbindliche bestellung
getätigt und wachsen wird ist noch nicht
zugelassen da sind wir aber auch mit dem
unternehmen bereits also in
gesprächen und werden uns dann ebenfalls
eine entsprechende
ausstattung zu legen zulegen das gilt
übrigens für alle medikamente die
zuverlässig also hier den schweren
verlauf verhindern können wir werden
dort alle möglichkeiten nutzen
jetzt geht es weiter mit der kollegin
kristin becker vermeiden
lauterbach er wieder sie haben ja betont
wie wichtig das testen jetzt vor
weihnachten noch mal ist und dass das
zentral ist ich habe deswegen jetzt die
letzten tage noch mal geschaut wie
bisschen mit dem schalter es aussieht
und zumindest mal in berlin gibt es
viele schnelltest aufzukaufen und die
fans zentren was mir dabei aber noch mal
aufgefallen ist es gibt ja diese tolle
liste von paul wo man nachschauen kann
was die qualität der test ausmachen und
in großen supermärkten in großen
programm streamer ketten sind die
schnelltests zum teil auf jeden fall
unterirdisch also quasi nicht zu nutzen
und sie werden massenhaft verkauft der
eine punkt wird auch im testzentrum
zumindest im privaten
da habe ich sozusagen geprüft und da
sind auch tests im umlauf die
unterirdisch schlecht sind ich frage
mich die amphoren gesagt der markt
regelt das mit dem schnelltest und es
sind im prinzip genug da das ist schön
dass welche da sind aber wenn sie gar
nichts bringen dann ist jedoch
ausgeschlossen dass geld und bei den
tests noch dazu geld das wir als
allgemeinheit für tests die nichts
bringen wo die leute einen fallschirm
sicherheitsgründen sie malt so anfrage
kommt deswegen die frage was was werden
sie da tun oder was haben sie da
vielleicht auch schon angedacht dagegen
vorzugehen so kann es ja nicht
weitergehen
ja zunächst einmal dass bei also testet
hd tests und stellt die ergebnisse also
ins netz so dass jeder sich selbst
informieren kann mein eindruck ist der
also dass die tests die besonders also
hochwertig sind den markt dominieren
also ich habe nicht den eindruck dass es
also anders ist ich schaue mir das aber
noch mal sehr gerne an dass sie sagen ja
jetzt also dass die test sie also jetzt
viel verkauft werden minderwertig werden
da habe ich andere informationen nicht
kraft das aber selbst noch mal geht es
sehr gern auf das bringt mich auf eine
andere frage die also hier wichtig ist
und naheliegend ist wirken die tests
eigentlich auch bei der omicron variante
und das ist also davon auszugehen die
test also fassen also einen teil des
also
der oberfläche des wehren ab die also
unverändert sind der tat der oberfläche
ist uns erinnert im vergleich dieser
variante omikron variante da die omega
und variante was sich also sogar den
nasen-rachen-raum explosionsartig also
verbreitet somit eine hohe viruslast
dort zu erwarten ist gehen wir davon aus
dass die also test bei der omicron
variante sehr zuverlässig funktionieren
dass auch die derzeitige studienlage
aber ich gehe ihre anregung noch einmal
nach ob tatsächlich also sehr weit
verbreitet es im angebot sind die auf
der grundlage der bewertung des paares
nicht
nicht nicht hochwertig sind ich wollte
mal nachfragen können sie das andere
micro nehmen schuldig habe es falsch
zugeordnet frage dazu wäre es denn
möglich von seiten des
gesundheitsministeriums dass sie
zumindest die tests hätten die privaten
und auch die öffentlichen aber fallen
auch die privaten verpflichten bei dem
test zu nehmen geht das zumindest bei
den supermärkten wahrscheinlich
schwieriger das geht nicht weil die
testzentren werden zugelassen mit allem
was dazugehört durch die euro länder und
die kommunen wir sind nicht die
betreiber der test sendern wir können
dort aber also empfehlungen geben und
ich greife ihre anregung auf und noch
einmal zu prüfen ob wir da ein defizit
haben
ich gucke ein bisschen auf die uhren
habe jedoch noch einige fragen eher an
den küster nochmal das signal das
scheint mir auch beantwortet jetzt eine
frage von anke schröder for managed care
japanisches fernsehen zur booster
impfung gibt es signale waren die
booster impfung für die zwölf- bis
17-jährigen beziehungsweise unter 18
allgemeinen zugelassen wird
das wissen wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch nicht ich bin mit den behörden im
gespräch
und hoffe dass wir das bald erreichen
können das ist ein großes problem weil
der impfschutz fehler erst bis
17-jährigen jetzt langsam also
abnimmt und wir müssen dieses problem
lösen da bin ich in gesprächen aber bis
jetzt kann ich da kann ich da nicht
anders kann das auch nicht vor geben in
dem sinne ich kann nur durch gespräche
kann ich versuchen das an zu reden jetzt
geht es ihm seit ich arbeite susanne
landwehr deutsche vertrags zeitung ich
habe eine frage hat in lauterbach und
zwar hat ihr haus gerade eine ein
entwurf änderungsentwurf vorgelegt für
die krone ein reiseverordnung
und es geht darum dass pcr tests
gefordert werden wenn jemand aus einem
virus varianten gebiet einreist und das
betrifft ja viel auch die
transportbranche also lkw-fahrer die
grenze überschreiten fahren
binnenschiffe die halt die
grenzüberschreitend fahren ist in dieser
verordnung eine ausnahmeregelung
vorgesehen dass also ja hier laufen kann
dass die lieferketten in der jetzigen
situation nicht unterbrochen werden oder
schnelle antwort ist nein weil das
ideologisch also nicht wirklich sinnhaft
wäre wenn wir hier eine ausnahme machen
worden aber natürlich gilt für das
transportgewerbe dass man sich zweimal
pro woche nur testen lassen muss das
halte ich aber auch für eine zumutbare
umsetzung das habe ich eine frage von
gernot heller von korrespondentenbüro
herholz an herrn lauterbach einige
länder auch baden-württemberg wollen
eine erneute ausrufung der epidemischen
lage mit komplettem instrumenten
glaskasten inklusive lockdown bleibt das
eine option
ich nehme und für den bund verstehe ich
jetzt hier was genau also es gibt hier
keine roten linien das habe ich ja schon
mehrfach gesagt aber auf der anderen
seite ist es so dass diese
position gestern bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nicht diskutiert wurde nicht vorgetragen
wurde und ich glaube mit den maßnahmen
die wir jetzt beschlossen haben können
wir das pandemische geschehen in den
nächsten wochen beherrschen ganz
grundsätzlich wie man hier nichts
ausschließen
wegen alles wenn es notwendig wäre jetzt
ist der punkt nicht gegeben jetzt geht's
wieder weiter andreas kienast der hertie
land noch einmal zu ihrer entscheidung
gestern und ihrer motivation so wie sie
es jetzt verteidigen hätten sie sich
doch einfach belassen können weil papier
des experten erwartet um montag hat sich
für sie die wagen geändert oder warum
haben sie geklaut es ist eine
zusätzliche
bedarf zu diesem zeitpunkt das sind
wirken sie abschätzen und die kosten
schätzen dass das öffentlich einen rum
also wie gesagt ich habe ging nicht mehr
zuzufügen als ich bereits gesagt habe
das ist ja die aufgabe des lka die
empfehlungen auszusprechen das tun wir
sind sogar verpflichtet zu
wenn sie überrascht
also
kann ich gar nichts zu sagen also ich
verfolge die nachrichten nicht so sehr
wie sie das vielleicht glauben insofern
habe ich gar keine einschätzung zu
ich mache nämlich meine arbeit und die
ist wissenschaftlich fundiert in erster
linie
jetzt habe ich noch ein zwei fragen von
patrick hollstein von apotheke adhoc die
ifa sich zusammen ist ein geht es um die
kosten der zusätzlich beschafften dosen
von herstellern oder aus dem ausland
auch frage ist ob das dem bund mehr
kostet als bislang
teil wurde ja schon vom
haushaltsausschuss freigegeben
und warum mussten sie das von ihrem
vorgänger bis zuletzt verteidigte er
rezept stoppen welche fehler wurden
gemacht wie geht es mit der gematik
weiter
das laser so zu den
preisen die wir hier zahlen müssen die
die preise sind geheim
und dass daher kann ich darüber nichts
sagen
und zum zweiten
dass ihr rezept also es gab noch nicht
unerhebliche technische
umsetzungsprobleme die sind nicht
bewältigt und also an der an der
bewältigung dieser probleme arbeiten wir
intensiv ich konnte jetzt nicht sehen
dass in der person
notlage in der sich zum teil die praxen
derzeit befinden aber auch die kliniken
wir arbeiten ja an der belastungsgrenze
eine weitere belastung durch die noch
nicht komplett vorbereitete einführung
an se rezept sinnvoll sein könnte
dankeschön dafür jetzt der klink für die
planung ich habe mal eine frage an den
minister der ethikrat hat jetzt sachen
impfpflicht auch seine empfehlung
herausgegeben es war gestern auch thema
bei der bundesländer beratung das so
beschleunigt jetzt passieren wann
rechnen sie damit dass der bundestag
sich mit dem thema beschäftigt
das kann ich nicht wirklich beantworten
das kommt darauf an wie schnell der
bundesbank hier vorgeht ich persönlich
will nur zwei dinge sagen ich bin
grundsätzlich der überzeugung dass das
eine ethik frage ist die der bundestag
so beantworten sollte das aus der mitte
des parlaments
entsprechende vorschläge gemacht werden
sollten wo jeder abgeordnete dann nach
besten wissen und gewissen seine also
entscheidung trifft ohne fraktionszwang
das ist das erste was ich sagen möchte
und zum zweiten werden dass solche
anträge geben wird dann also werde ich
sicherlich also einem antrag zustimmen
vielleicht auch an einem antrag
mitwirken der eine impfpflicht vorsieht
weil ich ohne eine impfpflicht
eine dauerhafte
bewältigung immer wieder neu
vorkommender wellen also ich sehen kann
und daher habe ich mich auch gefreut
dass der deutsche ethikrat
sich grundsätzlich für die prüfung einer
solchen pflicht ausspricht und in der
tendenz eher offen gegenübersteht
jetzt habe ich noch eine letzte frage
online von cordula eubel an herrn wider
erwarten sie dass angesichts der omicron
welle auch in deutschland im januar ein
harter lockdown notwendig sein wird
also ich wir beobachten diese lage und
wir
wir schauen was passiert mit nikon das
ist
eine frage die die abhängig von der
situation ist herr minister hat eben
gesagt dass es keine roten linien gibt
insofern ich glaube dass das wesentliche
ist dass wir uns immer an den fakten
orientieren damit fahren wir sicher am
besten und die werden wir im januar
scannen das wäre jetzt spekulation
ist frau die er gerade noch mal schickt
dass ihre frage nicht aufgerufen war
nicht liegt leider keine frage von ihr
vor insofern von ihnen vorfreude deshalb
kann ich leider auch nichts vortragen
gibt es noch eine sind jetzt schon ein
bisschen über die zeit gibt es noch
fragen im saal dann mache ich jetzt hier
nochmal der clips und dann wäre das für
heute die letzte es sei denn frau bist
noch mal ganz schnell
also ich hab richtig verstanden haben
laut schuster für kinder ist nicht
zugelassen aber der bund übernimmt die
haftung heißt das dass die eltern rate
von bereits zweimal gegen den kindern
gern im jetzt langsam abließen arzt oder
eine ärztin zu besuchen die diese
musterung machen
vielen dank ich rate nicht
sondern das muss der individuelle arzt
entscheiden ich bin zwar arzt aber ich
gebe keine empfehlungen quasi für die
bevölkerung ab 30 raten würde ist dass
man mit ärzten und ärztinnen spricht und
sich dann eine individuelle empfehlung
abholt
ok jetzt habe ich eine ich wollte jetzt
hier nicht noch mal rund mann voller ich
nehme jetzt nochmal einmal frau weil das
wohl nicht durchgekommen ist die fragt
wie lange der booster schutz bei omikron
anhält
so sehr gute frage das wissen wir nicht
da der schutz also zwischen wir wie das
auch ausführte korrekter weise zwischen
70 und 80 prozent liegt könnte es sein
dass der impfschutz also nicht
also also dauerhaft ist und darauf sind
wir vorbereitet und haben
mikronährstoffe
spezifischen mich vornehm stoff gekauft
beim unternehmen biontech insgesamt 80
millionen dosen mit denen wir rechnen
ab april oder mai je nachdem wann der
impfstoff im größeren volumen vorhanden
ist würden aber dann auch wieder
zusätzlich moderner impfstoff beschaffen
so dass wir nicht auf einen impfstoff
gebucht sind und eine auswahl anbieten
können aber ich würde persönlich als
wissenschaftler davon ausgehen dass wir
davon ausgehen müssen dass eine
sogenannte vierte impfung das wäre es
dann ja dass die notwendig sein wird
darf jetzt noch ich mache jetzt noch
eine allerletzte frage hier
offensichtlich fast nicht durchgekommen
ist von frau mißlbeck von den ärzten
nachdem ärzte nachrichtendienst die nach
der haftungsfrage bei impfungen für
unter- fünfjährigen fragt wie das
geregelt ist
ja bei unter fünfjährigen ist ja der
impfstoff nicht zugelassen und somit
also ist da also keine haftung durch den
bund jetzt vorgesehen dass er nicht
zugelassener impfstoff da gelten dann
die regeln die typischerweise gelten
wenn wenn man also hier ins risiko geht
reviews das ist dann oft dass es ein
ganz klassischer off-label-use und einen
off label use muss sehr gut begründet
werden
also ich wurde hier also ich will ihnen
da nicht vorgreifen aber ich würde hier
also
ich würde hier ich wäre hier also das
wäre meine empfehlung an die kolleginnen
und kollegen hier wäre ich äußerst
zurückhaltend weil also im rahmen des
off label
haftungsrecht ist also ihr könnt ich mir
vorstelle ist das sehr schwer
darzustellen und dann danke ich
eigentlich fragen gestellt haben ich
habe mein bestes getan dass wir hier
durchkommen mit eintragen ich hoffe dass
das auch geklappt hat ich danke unseren
gästen für ihr kommen herr lauterbach
lassen und ich nehme an wir sehen uns
mit den alten nicht allzu ferner zeit
hier wieder
dankeschön schließe die pressekonferenz
[Musik]